all right
ariel yeah ariel where'd you grow up
where are you from
originally south central and tell me
about your family you had both your
parents as a kid
um i only had my mother where was dad
and i just met him last year actually
and he's in austin texas
and how was your childhood with mom um
very rough very rough i was always like
the black sheep in my family
i was always the room i've been to run
away since the baby
and it was it was tough i was
molested and by family members you know
and it just
scarred me up and just made me why i'm
saying what age of that kind of stuff
start
9 10. you started running away when
10 11. yeah
and then what kind of kid were you in
high school
i was bad i dropped out at night in
ninth grade
and you started working the streets at
what age
pain was 15 15 and up to this point
i have a i have a son with a guy i don't
even know
one of your one of your customers yeah
and uh you have one one child
yeah i have two yeah are you raising
them no
they went to the foster system i'm still
out here man
no but the kids are no i i won my case i
had four years clean
and i won my case and they gave them
back to me
and my mom just i i just told my mom i
cut i can't do it and
she took my kiss like because she's like
they're still under my name i couldn't
you know like they're not from the
system i have four years cleaning like i
said nothing
so your kids are with your mom yeah i
see and you're using drugs
yes which what's your drug you know i
just started
shooting
heroin yeah yeah
and uh so you're working with a pimp or
without a pimp
sorry are you working with a pimp or
without no without without
so tell me about that lifestyle is it
it's what are the worst things about
doing this for a living i think
like just looking like just after you
shower
after being with a guy like you just
have to mean as a woman like just feels
wrong off gate you know
and sometimes i don't understand why i
do what i do you know but
i feel like i have a lot to do with like
being touched it's got to be hard right
do you have any respect for the guys
that pick you up you can't right no
and has it changed the way you view men
in general
i think men are dogs that's it
and just as dogs as men are and women
can be too
yeah have you been beaten up or
things like that what's what are some of
the worst things that's happened
being locked in the room with 10 guys
i'm sorry being locked in a room with 10
guys
i need to find a way out
it's horrible
and then they're looking for you oh you
have to hide under cars and everything
and it's got to take your self-esteem
has to take a hit after doing this kind
of stuff right
yeah i clogged around my happy and
laughing all that but deep down it's
just
covered my pain and the heroin
helps with that any type of drug yeah
anything or everything to make me feel
not i'm sure you see a direct line
between what happened to you as a kid
with your family and
where you are today it's like a straight
line right
yeah and i just that like my mom was a
promoter
so she's like she traveled around the
world
with like famous artists and she always
gave me everything i wanted
i think that's why i did what i did and
she was she was always traveling and my
cousin was always blessed to be you know
so like i didn't know how to deal with
it or i don't know how to bring it up to
her because i don't know what was wrong
you know i didn't know i needed to touch
right there or nothing like that
so i think
i got i got like i got so
accustomed to the feeling that i came to
believe that it was right
and and that's just me
i went to the streets and started
getting pain i'm saying myself
except for protected by my head
in the drug use it's been going on for
about
15 years now is it getting better or
worse or
um actually i got clean for four years
and i stopped using and just realized
about eight months ago
what would cause you to relax
i think i'm not being able like
to be a mother to my kids
not being able to love myself like i
didn't know where to start i didn't know
how to do it
that's what made me relax because my
body's like so used to moving around
here
and so when it starts something new it's
like
i get out of my comfort zone
yeah that's what made me relapse and
you've been doing this a long time it
almost it's because yeah that's all i
know how to live you know so it's like
it's it's like a routine you can't even
see that it's crazy
because as an outsider this is like why
would you ever yeah like yeah yeah yeah
and
it's it's amazing though those four
years i had clean like
and i went to austin and i lived with my
father like
and it was amazing it was i don't know
what was wrong
and i still don't know you came back to
this
yeah i took a turn off school i'm
supposed to graduate next month then i
still can't get back
do you think that
your self-worth takes a hit by what
happened to you when you were
a young girl and then it makes you
believe that this is all you deserve
and then when you have a better life
like you had those four years in austin
it almost
doesn't feel right yeah right exactly
exactly
it's crazy but he's like that so if a
good guy came into your life or a better
situation like you had in austin you
can't accept it
yeah because i'm broken inside yeah if
i'm broken and everything around me is
broken
that's what i see over and over
and i'm sure you get depressed by this
existence yeah and that's why i'm not
around my kids because if i don't know
how to love myself i can't love anybody
else
what do you see as a way out for you
it's almost like you need
years of therapy or a new childhood
i just don't know how to forgive
anything
yeah forgive myself
i beat myself up every every day
like why can't i just be a mother to my
kids
why can't i just stop [ __ ] having sex
like what's the purpose behind it when i
get money i waste it and just keep going
and going like where am i going with
this
you're not saving right
but it's just like i'm doing it out of
pain or i really don't know where
you get addicted to the whole lifestyle
right yeah
that's the real it's like a thrill a
dream
even though it's abusive and dangerous
and
yeah and leading you nowhere you still
get hooked on it yeah
i'm sorry it's tough out here it's
really tough
especially for us woman
have you been in love before have i been
alone before
nah i i don't know what love is
honestly i know what a parent's love is
but it's a different type of
how old are you i'm 25 25.
if you were to meet somebody that was a
potential partner for you
this lifestyle would certainly get in
the way right
a guy would have a hard time with what
you're doing of course
of course so you're almost blocking
yourself from ever finding a partner
i i'm i honestly i'm not really looking
for a partner because like i said like
what type of woman i this is how i feel
what type of women
will give their time to a guy
when you've got your kids waiting for
you at home and only a real man will see
that
so i had nobody give up the time that i
could get to my kids over a guy
i just give to the streets mom
i see it i no no no no two votes two
broken batteries
two broken batteries they'll start a car
that's interesting so you're still very
young but
do you still have hope for a better life
for i believe it i know i'm gonna make
it out one day
you're gonna i don't know well good for
you i know i'll make sure i will well
you seem self-aware enough to do that
i had four years on my belt already so
i'm pretty i'm pretty sure
like like this time i could i could like
i don't i i never wanted to stay with
the the thinking like
what if i tried one more time what am i
trying one more time now oh i tried it
one more time look where i'm at
so i have four years now i think next
time i get cleaned up i'm done
good for you you know looking back you
sound like you have the right
way of thinking it's just you have to
do the hard work of actually doing it
yeah
what advice would you give to a girl
who's considering doing something like
this yeah
two
to find yourself
find out who you are who you want to be
and get to where you want to be
so you can never say well what if
i would have done that just follow your
dreams
know your self-worth
that's all
do you consider like every time you get
into a car with a guy that
disgusting i feel disgusted
disgusted when i get in the shower and
everything
disgust
and you have to worry about whether your
kids will have a mom one day because
yeah that guy can do anything well yep
they would choke your ass to death man
it will stab you it's just all types of
things gonna happen man
you never know you're gonna make it out
back
my biggest fear not meaning to
accomplish to be a mother to my kids
to go out with my mom when i get sick
you know my momma died that was like
that's my biggest fear
yeah so it's not like you're making
these decisions consciously it's almost
like the
the terrible childhood you had set you
up for this beats me and follow me
everywhere i go it's a curse
i can never forget those
you know
and i pray never happens to nobody else
especially my son because i have an
autistic then
and my son don't speak his nonverbal
so when my son gets home from school
i'll check his diaper and die
like like his hands his arm is
like
a special kid you know you know he's
right he don't know what's wrong with
him
how often do you see your kids i can see
them any day anytime but i refuse
to step in the house and leave again and
in and out
that's the thing with my kids emotions
like no
that's a big nose so i just stay out
here
and when i stay in i stay can i get some
autism oh sure
so when i say and i stay in when i stay
out
i stay out i don't like walking in and
out so i just like mentally
messing them up you know and you get you
get
hassled by pimps and guys on the street
like that
they try to give me some time like they
try to buy me like
like they try to like make some make me
make money with him
like that no i could do it by myself man
i don't know
no that's a big no like i just give my
own money
i have you know that's the reason women
have pimps because they need protection
but i don't feel like we need protection
when you're packing by yourself and
you've got your own guns
you've been arrested before yes it has
that's typically a short short time yeah
yeah it's just in and out eight months
how long eight months no i did it 19
months you kind of jumped oh is that
right
yeah for what oh yeah but for
prostitution it's in and out
no prostitution i've never gotten any
kind of resistation
okay
cops never see me like that they'd be
trying to get on me
like it's like i was just in in the tank
not that long ago and they were trying
he was trying doing his best trying to
give me his number through the tank
like and then
they even dismissed my case
i'm even cogs most of them are molesters
trust me you'll be surprised
are you gonna let that power get to
their head
but what was the best time of your life
it was priceless
nothing good everybody that
that was the last best moment in my life
when i saw love both eyes
all right ariel well thank you so much
for talking with me i hope you get back
with your
with your voice okay thank you
you